disturbing surveillance video reveals
how the attack that killed an american
in greece began
and how it ended local media say the
footage shows bakari henderson running
from a group of men
they then throw him down kick and punch
him numerous times
it happened outside a bar on the island
of zaquinthos
tony decopol is here with new details on
how the violence quickly escalated tony
really hard to watch this footage
indeed good morning the video is now
court evidence and police confirm
it's genuine it shows that fewer than 20
seconds passed between the time the
group
began pummeling bakari henderson and the
time they stepped away from his lifeless
body and we're also learning more
about what led to this brutal attack
from video
inside the bar security footage shows a
man and a woman taking a selfie
next to a person greek media say is
bakari henderson
moments later a man next to henderson
grabs a bottle of beer and makes a
smashing motion
setting off a confrontation that
escalates when the man hits henderson on
the head
a few seconds later henderson hits back
the men then run out of view
surveillance video from a nearby bar
shows henderson trying to run away
before someone throws him against the
car several others begin to kick
and punch him as he collapses in the
street bystanders try to break up the
attack
and someone appears to give henderson
cpr greek authorities say henderson died
from
severe head injuries nine men face
voluntary manslaughter charges including
seven
serbians and two workers from the bar
one of those workers a bouncer
told a local paper he tried to break up
the fight but that henderson took an
ashtray and threw it at me
he admits he responded by punching him
in the face and two or three times
in the body i've never seen him rattled
a day in my life
henderson's friend daniel brown spoke
with cbs news in greece this week
he was with henderson on the island of
zaquintos
but he says he wasn't at the bar in the
party district of lagunas when the fight
broke out
he told us henderson a recent college
graduate who was working to start his
own clothing line
was a selfless person who always kept
his cool
he was never really worried about
material objects
or social status or anything like that
and he was non-judging of everyone he
met
and because of that he easily had the
most diverse and large group of friends
anyone could ask for
four suspects appeared in court today
for initial testimony
back in texas meanwhile a spokeswoman
for henderson's family tells us they're
planning memorial services for friday
and saturday she says they're hoping to
have his body back home
by then oh geez and that's likely you
think it seems like it now
thank you tony